all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to Pearl pissed off Twitter now
I know before you guys
come at me I'm sorry I just came from
the gym and sometimes I just have these
thoughts so today today I pissed off the
Twitter universe and
there's a lot of serious tweeters on
this app and I'm now in the serious
business of tweeting so what did I tweet
I said how can we as women see these
numbers
and think we're doing good as a whole
just as a group one in four women have
an STD one in three women have had an
abortion 38 of kids are born in single
parent homes the age of first child is
26 the age of first marriage is 30. 45
percent of marriages end in divorce
women initiate divorce 70 of the time
our average number of sexual partners is
between four and eight
and let's be honest the men think we're
capping about this anyway they think
it's way higher and once you've slept
with more than five people your chance
of a happy marriage goes from like I
don't know 20 to 30 percent roughly
um 70 of women are overweight ninety
percent of women have used
contraceptives at one point in their
reproductive years and most have used
more than one Reaper more than one
contraceptive method throughout our
lifetime and you know knowing that the
majority of the time when women break up
marriages
um we get custody and knowing the
effects of single mother homes when
we're more likely to go to prison more
likely to drop out of school more likely
to be homeless more likely to grow up 80
of um kids that grow up and rape women
are from single mother homes knowing
that these are the effects of our poor
decisions okay knowing that if we do not
increase the birth rate which is about
1.2
um
and knowing that they're predicting or
knowing that if we do not increase the
birth rate that societies tend to
collapse when women do not increase the
birth rate knowing that the average
number of kids is like 1.5 nowadays
knowing
that were than ever before or
fatter than ever before why
does everybody say I hate on women when
the numbers say that unprecedentedly
women we are the worst we have ever been
in all human history women need to
improve we need to improve
um and I know what you're thinking
you just harp on women well when I look
at our self-improvement stuff guys it's
nonsense it's it's go to
therapy write in a journal and feel
better about yourself and be confident
it's the most full of I've
ever heard and simps co-sign it and lie
to us and say oh men need to be more no
no no no no no no women need to be more
because
unprecedentedly we are the worst we have
ever been in human history so where do
women start okay
where did I just come from the gym
that is one thing that all women can do
we can always be in better shape we can
always aim to stay in better shape two
where else can we improve not leaving
the men we choose to marry and have
children with
I'm sorry ladies
kick your bed and lie in it you cannot
pick a man to have a child with make
that decision and then later say that
you're not going to work it out in the
name of your happiness our happiness
doesn't matter and that's the thing that
our great-grandmothers and our
great-grandmothers understood marriage
is not about happiness life is not about
happiness we are here for something that
is bigger than us it is not about us
because when we make decisions for our
happiness
Society suffers there are there are more
homeless people there are more grapes
there are more single mother homes there
are more men in prison you know the same
men the same men that we complain about
the grapists the murderers the ultra
aggressive men we create from the
decisions that we make
and Society is crumbling before our eyes
the US will not be a world superpower in
a hundred years because of the decisions
that Western women have taken the second
that we got the freedom to do so
and as much as we want to blame society
as much as we want to blame everybody
else it is our own decisions now
at some point women we wake up and we
realize that certain decisions do not
have good outcomes and you know what
there are some decisions you can't
change right
but
there's nothing stopping you from not
creating kids out of marriage there's
nothing stopping you from getting in
better shape there's nothing stopping
you from becoming more agreeable and for
actually catering to what men want men
always cater to what we want why is it
crazy for us to cater to what they want
for once and for for a change why is it
crazy to strive to be better wives
girlfriends and honestly just women in
society and this isn't coming at this
isn't me saying that I'm perfect and I
don't have places that I need to improve
I certainly do but it's actually crazy
that you cannot criticize women in this
Society we cannot say hey we need to be
better without
Sims coming in and saying no no no the
men need to be better without bitter
women coming in and saying no no no
we're perfect the way we are we're
queens and we're 10 and this mentality
this we are perfect the way we are
mentality is what's ruining Society
um yeah so welcome to my TED talk let me
know what you guys think in the comments
uh like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell I'll talk to you next
time